uh just a few questions i can just save
you some time
i've had over 30 000 drinks
i don't really chew my food and i'm like
barreling towards 40.
i just meant like any pre-existing
conditions
i'm a woman
you ladies are looking for trouble
tonight i can feel it
all right behave yourself
we're too old to be here right i think
march rack is still open
i should definitely get it right mm-hmm
spread love
i feel pretty ready for a new start i'm
done selling wine i have an appointment
with a wine manager cork and fork
magazine called it
drinkable
whoa my boyfriend he always says i seem
like i'm 100. hey hey babe
at this point i'm just following him
around like some sad
loser
i like really had it together up until
two weeks ago so please
i look in the mirror for love i was
thinking i could come out to long island
it went that bad and he took the break
up like a total champ uh-huh
we're both just being completely adult
about it i'm never dating again you're
saying that now and in a couple of
months you're gonna shave that bush how
do you know i have a bush right now you
got a big bush i can tell like two feet
up you are a natural-born salesman but
you have to find the thing that gives
you that charge i'm supposed to ask you
for a tour these are stinging nettles
can i pick one you harvest them got it
use it in a sentence i should have
harvested my eggs
it feels so good to be out here what's
his name her and i never named them oh
delicious rabbit liver
rabbit that's why i don't name them
i gotta find my thing and i believe that
i was meant to coach
okay get down defense
oh god i'm sorry
i really like him but i've spent a lot
of time on guys that i knew weren't
right
sometimes our mental pain manifests in
our bodies
[Music]
i'm finally listening to my instincts
and i'm going for what i want i'll stay
but only to make sure he's not a
murderer i'm not a murderer oh my god hi
want to come inside where i won't murder
you
global warming it's so sad but like what
can we do stop buying plastic bottles
this was a gift
[Music]